this entire brown long she made
headlines when she was sentenced to life
in prison
she was only 16 at the time for killing
a man who she says picked her up for sex
then Tennessee Governor Bill Haslam
called her case tragic and complex she
was granted clemency earlier this year
after spending 15 years behind bars now
she's 31 she shares an intimate advice
for her 16 year old self as part of our
series we call note to self
dear Santa I know you're anxious and you
feel alone right now but I want you to
know that God hears you you don't have a
driver's license you haven't voted or
even made it to prom you understand why
you're here isn't but today you're in
juvenile court praying that you will not
be tried as an adult
brown claims Alan was reaching for a gun
when she shot him I'm thinking soon here
do something like it but then he rolls
over and reaches like he's reaching to
the side of the bed or something so I'm
thinking oh he's not gonna hit me he's
gonna get a gun I just grabbed the gun
in our shadow and although you will be
told that you're gonna die in prison I'm
here to tell you that's a lie
a wild swing of events is about to take
place that will cause you to question
whether God even exists but just keep
your faith and trust me when I say he
hears you I know right now it seems like
all you ever hear is talk of what a
horrible person you are you've been
called a [ __ ] a murderer encourage of
all but I want you to know that you are
so much more than the worst thing that
you've ever done I know that as a little
girl you felt like an outcast when kids
talked about your hair or skin color and
this moment is no exception
but know that a day will come when you
could care less what people think of you
there's a fire that burns inside of you
that will eat up any obstacle that dares
to stand in your way
you don't realize that yet
but you are bigger than anything that
anyone tried to do to hurt you yes there
will be many lonely nights to lie ahead
of you
you'll spend some time believing that
the world is against you and that you
may never be happy again
you'll be exploited and mistreated by
people for years to come including your
own biological mother
and you'll have your hopes of freedom
dashed repeatedly though it's like your
character your family your marriage your
faith but none of what they have to say
defines your self-worth or your
happiness stay focused on your calling
you will learn that there are many
people from all parts of the world who
support you who believe in you that you
see to the restoration of Miss Brown to
our community I visit Santoya every week
and it's just been such a pleasure to
get to know her please allow her the
opportunity to give back to society you
will know once again that happiness is
meant for you too
and through the people who mistreated
you
you will know forgiveness and it will
bring you a freedom that you can enjoy
even when in prison most importantly
though
you will forgive yourself it'll be hard
and it'll take many years but you will
love yourself again
you can't see it now but God is gonna
use you in a mighty way through you he
will give a voice to the voiceless you
will speak up at every opportunity to
encourage justice freedom and mercy for
the oppressed and that prayer you prayed
the one where you promised God to tell
the world about him if he freed you that
will come to fruition as well
you'll one day get the chance to tell
the world every detail of your journey
there the system and how God freed you
from it all never forget what I told you
from the beginning God does hear you
beautiful letter when she said happiness
is meant for you - she did have a lot of
support many people had never heard of
her case and once you heard of her case
you couldn't believe that this young
woman was behind bars for as long as she
was it's great for many people to see
that she I like when she said
forgiveness will bring you freedom yeah
it's a very powerful thing and you are
more than the worst thing you've ever
done it's absolutely true a lot of
people still pulling for usin Toya Brown
long her new memoir it's called free
Santoya my search for redemption
and the American prison system is
available now wherever you like to buy
your books it's published by atria books
which is an imprint of Simon & Schuster
which as you probably know is owned by
CBS